tenemos un montón de números aquí arriba
y mi objetivo en este vídeo es ver si
podemos clasificarlos en los diferentes
tipos de categorías de números así que
déjame dibujar las categorías este
primer círculo que voy a dibujar justo
aquí en este que estoy dibujando de
morado va a representar a todos aquellos
números que se pueden ver como un
cociente de dos números enteros y por
supuesto el denominador no puede ser
cero porque no sabemos lo que significa
poner como denominador al cero así que
vamos a llamar a este cociente entre dos
enteros con el nombre de números
racionales lo voy a poner aquí
rahm
nacionales son justos estos de aquí y
bueno algo que no pueda ser representado
como un cociente de dos números enteros
va a ser este círculo de rojo
estos de aquí van a ser los números
irracionales perfecto estos de aquí van
a ser los i
ra
si nadie es decir todos aquellos números
que no se pueden representar como el
consciente de dos enteros y bueno el
tamaño de estos círculos no muestra que
tan grandes son estos conjuntos de hecho
existe una infinidad de números
racionales y una infinidad de números
irracionales y racionales los que no se
pueden expresar como un cociente de dos
enteros y ahora adentro de los
racionales
tenemos a los enteros instalados así que
los voy a poner con este color
dentro de los racionales por aquí
tenemos al dos números enteros
escribirlo
pero los enteros que bueno son aquellos
números que no tienen que ser
representados como fracción o decimal y
ahora un subconjunto de los números
enteros son los números naturales que
voy a poner con este color aquí adentro
voy a tener a los números naturales
tú reales es decir aquellos enteros que
no son negativos y bueno sería bueno
escribir que estos son números números y
bueno estos también son números estos
también son números
pero si bueno estos de aquí también son
números los números irracionales los
números racionales los números enteros y
los números naturales y bueno ahora sí
vamos a categorizar estos siguientes
números así que como siempre es momento
de que pau ses este vídeo ideas en qué
categoría entra cada uno de estos
números y en donde podrías poner a cada
uno de ellos en este diagrama así que
empecemos con el 3 este 3 es positivo
definitivamente se puede representar
como un cociente de dos enteros lo
puedes representar como 3 sobre 1 pero
no tiene que ser forzosamente
representado como una fracción puede ser
solamente un 3 por aquí pero además es
no negativo por lo tanto el 3 es un
número natural es un miembro de este
conjunto y recuerda si eres un miembro
de los naturales también eres un entero
y también eres un número racional
por eso el 3 es un número natural y un
entero y un racional así que lo voy a
atrapar
su respectivo color verde y ahora
pensemos en el -5 el -5 en definitiva se
puede representar como una fracción pero
no forzosamente entonces hasta ahorita
es un entero lo podría poner por aquí
sin embargo date cuenta que es un número
negativo por lo tanto no puede ser un
número natural entonces menos 5 va a
estar situado justo aquí en los números
enteros y en definitiva si es un número
entero es un número racional pero en
este caso no es un número natural porque
es negativo así que lo vamos a tratar
con el color azul ahora tenemos al 0.25
el 0.25 bueno este tiene por seguro que
lo podemos escribir como una fracción un
cociente de dos enteros esto es lo mismo
que 25 sobre 100 sobre 100 y por lo
tanto es un número racional ya que lo
podemos escribir como un cociente de dos
números enteros
ahora date cuenta que no existe una
forma en la cual esté 0.25 se puede
representar de otra manera sólo se puede
representar usando una fracción entonces
el 0.25 va a ser un número racional y lo
voy a poner por aquí 0.25 es un número
racional pero no es un entero y tampoco
es un número natural y que hay del 22
séptimos bueno claramente está
representado como un cociente de dos
enteros y si te das cuenta este número
tampoco lo podemos representar de otra
manera excepto como una fracción de dos
enteros
no puedo representar a este número
excepto usando una presión o un decimal
que se repite así que este también va a
ser un racional pero no será un entero
natural lo voy a escribir aquí 22
séptimos y ahora que hay el que sigue
desde aquí 0 27 13 repitiéndose bueno
pues este de aquí el 0.27 13 y el 13 se
repite este es el 0.27 13 33 esto es lo
que representa la línea de arriba puede
ser que tú todavía no lo sepas pero
cualquier número que se repite
eventualmente esto se repite
eventualmente pues tenemos puntos 27 13
13 13 cualquier número como éste se
puede representar como una fracción por
ejemplo este no lo voy a hacer por aquí
por cuestiones de tiempo pero por
ejemplo el 0.3 repitiéndose esto es lo
mismo que un tercio y seguramente
después hablaremos de estas técnicas de
cómo convertir esto a una fracción de
dos enteros pero para este vídeo lo
importante es saber que se puede
representar como un cociente de
enteros como por ejemplo aquí el 0.3
repitiéndose es lo mismo que un tercio y
entonces lo pondremos en los números
racionales es decir aquí va a ir el 0.27
13 repitiéndose ahora si éste se puede
ver como una fracción de dos enteros o
como un decimal entonces no se puede ver
como un entero pero ten cuidado no lo
vayas a confundir con un irracional y
por lo tanto lo voy a atrapar con el
color morado de lujo ahora el que sigue
sigue la raíz de 10 y este es bastante
interesante la raíz de 10 ahora
cualquier raíz de un número que no sea
un cuadrado perfecto va a ser irracional
y por lo tanto este va a ser un número
racional entonces no te lo estoy
probando pero no lo puede representar
como una fracción de dos enteros este lo
voy a poner aquí no se puede representar
como un cociente de dos enteros es decir
un entero en el numerador y un entero en
el denominador
de otra manera si no quieres representar
como un decimal este nunca se va a
repetir
solamente se mantendrían saliendo nuevos
y nuevos y nuevos dígitos este nunca se
repetirá en ningún momento así que es de
aquí la raíz de 10 es un número
irracional y no se puede representar
como una fracción un cociente de dos
enteros
ahora fijémonos en este de aquí 14 sobre
7 lo primero que te das cuenta es que 14
sobre 7
este es un cociente de dos enteros
entonces por seguro es un racional pero
si piensas un poco en el 14 séptimos
este de aquí lo podemos expresar como 2
esto es exactamente lo mismo que tener 2
entonces este es un número natural se ve
como un número racional porque es un
consciente de dos enteros pero no
forzosamente se puede representar como
un cociente de dos enteros
no se necesita representar forzosamente
como una fracción y bueno si te das
cuenta es positivo así que lo podemos
representar simplemente como 2
214 séptimos es lo mismo que dos y es un
número natural 14 sobre 7 es lo mismo
que 2 y es un número natural ahora
pasemos al 2 pi que hay con el 2000
bueno pues en definitiva pi es un número
irracional y ahora lo que quiero que
veas en este momento es que cualquier
múltiplo de pib o más bien cualquier
múltiplo entero de pin también va a ser
un número irracional y por lo tanto dos
pies sería por aquí 2 pin es un número
irracional si nos fijamos en su
representación decimal ésta nunca se
repetirá así que bueno 2 pi es
irracional y ahora que hay de la raíz
negativa de 25 menos la raíz de 25 bueno
pues 25 es un cuadrado perfecto entonces
la raíz cuadrada de 25 y 5 y con este
signo menos esto me quedaría como menos
así que esta cosa de aquí es lo mismo
que menos 5 y si te das cuenta esto ya
lo habíamos hecho es justo este caso que
tenemos aquí es un número entero no es
un número natural porque es negativo
pero es entero así que lo voy a poner
aquí la menos raíz cuadrada de 25 es
decir que estos dos son exactamente lo
mismo son el mismo número sólo que son
distintas formas de representarlo y
bueno por último tenemos a la raíz de 9
sobre 7 pero cuál es la raíz principal
de 9 bueno pues esta cosa de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que la raíz
principal de 9 es 3 3 sobre 7 3 séptimos
raíz de 9 entre 7 es lo mismo que 3
séptimos y si te das cuenta este es un
número racional porque es un cociente de
dos enteros y va aquí lo voy a poner
aquí raíz de 9 sobre
raíz de 9 sobre 7 que es lo mismo que 3
séptimos que 3 séptimos y bueno ya para
acabar déjame hacer uno más sólo para
divertirnos que hay del número pi pi
sobre ping en qué categoría meto a este
número bueno y sobre ping esto es
exactamente lo mismo que uno así que en
realidad este es un número natural así
que podemos escribirlo aquí bien sobre
ping es un número natural porque esta es
una forma elegante de decir 1